ええええええん
結構よ
建前で with はじめ
ちょっと大主9意味ですね
まぁちょっとイギリスにセットと鳥という混ぜ危険な状況で撮るんですけど
海外のモンスターを総会している人が結構見るんですけど
エックスプレッソモンスター
お城とエクスプレススポンサーの袋です
me
ん
ちょっと暗くてごめんね
あのポストホビーの家でを取りたいんですけど
ちょっとなぁ
ちょっと恥ずかしいんでここでトロせていただきますコーヒーとモンスターが合体した
って言う
何度 fantastic and crazy な商品がね
イギリスにはあるんですけどこっちからです
にょ庵さん前にコーヒーです
骨の白いほうはなんか
普通にカフェお礼ですね全然エナジードリンク缶がもうなくなっちゃってる感じです
あのモンスターとコーヒーなんて絶対合わないと思ったけど
意外と飲んだらいけます黒い歩数
あこっちは大丈夫かなぁと思います
彼は水だめだ黒はダメだこちら
こっちが飛ぶカフェオレねー
こっちは多分
なんか裏って恋からもう
まじ良くないですね
こっちがもういいですねまじねちょっと留学したほうがいいです本当に
あんまりしゃべれなくてもなんとかなるんできっと
というわけでぜひモンスター
なかなかね買う機会ないと思うんですけど
日本にこれが発売することを買ったら
黒じゃなくてこっちの舞方を飲んでみてください
外国のモンスター紹介する人めっちゃ見るからしたくなかったんですけど
これはねー
ロッツ6もっとないですからね
wh